[Music]
sharks
and dolphins this vicious rivalry has
been raging for
millions of years two australian
oystermen get a firsthand look at the
aftermath of a battle oh my god
another one massive one massive one
look at it oh they just come out from
underneath the boat
the moment i saw the second shark
adrenaline started
pumping through my veins i i didn't know
what just happened
oh basket
the second shark was bigger than the
first it would have been 12 to 14 foot
probably but it was
definitely bigger it was huge
wait wait they're playing they're
fighting they're fighting their points
he just stole that dolphin three
pointers he just stole the dolphin
oh look at the size of that thing a
dolphin is worth fighting over
we do know that if shark gets the
opportunity to eat a dolphin
they absolutely will in fact it's a
really
prized food source like many marine
mammals dolphins have all this blubber
so it's that's a good nutritious meal
from the injuries
it's clear the dolphin was initially
attacked from behind
and below
how did the shark get past this
dolphin's defenses
dolphins are really quite zippy
they can outmaneuver a shark fairly
easily especially if they're in
deeper or open water spaces
to understand how sharks catch these
slippery creatures
the team heads to a beach that offers a
unique look at
shark bay's dolphins so we're right now
at monkey maya in shark bay
there has been 20 years of really
incredible ecological and biological
research on the interactions between
sharks and dolphins
dolphins were first drawn here in the
1960s
by fishermen sharing their catch today
the site is regulated by the parks and
wildlife service
we have some friendly dolphins that come
here very regularly and we get to see
them up close and personal which is
really special
no need for a baited underwater camera
here dolphins come to you and they're
covered in scars
so this individual that's just
approaching us just now is called
piccolo and you can
see on her dorsal and on her back she's
got scars from encounters with sharks
dolphins make this trade-off a lot of
the food that they want
most and the easy fishing grounds the
yummy fish occur around
shallow seagrass beds unfortunately
that's also where tiger sharks
preferentially like to hunt to protect
themselves
dolphins have a secret weapon
echolocation
they can send out a beam of sound from a
fatty part of their head
called the melon the sound beam bounces
back and forms a mental image in the
dolphin's brain of the world around them
echolocation is a way that dolphins have
to see in dark and low-lit
environments basically it's like radar
or sonar
but there are limits to this superpower
so it works kind of like wide beams on a
flashlight they can only see
kind of directly ahead of them or to the
sides so if they get attacked from the
back or from underneath they probably
won't see the predator coming
dolphins have a blind spot and sharks
know it
he's got a dolphin in his mouth great
whites use their massive power to charge
from beneath
in a breach attack white sharks you
would consider more of an ambush
predator
it's probably the shark that you don't
see that you worry about because a lot
of flight sharks
rely on surprise they're stealth
predators
it's easy to sneak up on a lone dolphin
but the safety of the pod can stop an
ambush even from a great white
a white shark swims with a group of
dolphins
the ocean-going mammals show no concern
for the killer in their midst their
ability to communicate and spot their
stalker
gives the shark no chance at an attack
[Music]
you